le travail c'est la santé comme le
chantait henri salvador oui mais à quel
prix c'est du moins la question qu'on se
pose aujourd'hui à compter du 31 août le
pass sanitaire sera obligatoire pour
tous les employés des lieux recevant du
public sans ce précieux sésame
ces salarié s'expose à une suspension de
leur contrat de travail et donc à
l'interruption du versement de leur
rémunération jusqu'à la régularisation
de la situation
pas de licenciement donc mais ce n'est
pas le même son de cloche pour isabey
devant je crois qu'il faut être clair
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il ne peut pas
y avoir de licenciements
cela veut dire qu'il est moins encadré
peut-être qu'il pourra intervenir plus
tôt on est dans le droit commun du droit
du travail
alors concrètement qui sera concerné par
ce pass sanitaire est bien tous les
employés qui sont susceptibles de
recevoir du public dans le cadre de leur
activité professionnelle ce qui englobe
les salariés des salles de sport des
cinémas piscines lieux de loisirs bars
cafés restaurants ou bien encore des
centres commerciaux et bien évidemment
les soignants pour lesquelles la
vaccination est obligatoire à partir du
15 septembre
une mesure qui risque de provoquer
quelques désertion on m'oblige à faire
un vaccin qui n'est pour moi
quand est et qui est très dangereux pour
l'être humain donc je trouve la santé et
donc je prône le non accès et
je prononce et notre liberté de pouvoir
au nom sans injecter un produit qui
n'est pas encore j'irai jusqu'au
licenciement jusqu'à la mise à pied jeu
tant pis j'aurais pu en carrière mais
c'est pas grave je tiendrai bon jusqu'au
bout
vous l'aurez compris la tentation d'un
départ professionnel pourrait s'étendre
à bien d'autres catégories
professionnelles
car l'idée même de faire un test toutes
les 48 heures semble très compliqué à
mettre en place pour les employeurs même
si une possible affectations temporaires
à un autre poste nous ont soumis au
passage iter est envisageable
les flous juridiques sont nombreux et la
logistique plus que jamais remise en
question qui va contrôler le pass
sanitaires là encore question
normalement c'est pas à l'employeur 11
tout le monde comprend que tout ce qui
concerne la santé des gens s'endettent
secret médical l'employeur n'a pas
évidemment interférer là-dedans principe
c'est la médecine du travail kaka
revient
je ne sais pas qui la contrôle sanitaire
médecin du travail en principe c'est lui
mais c'est ingérable
dans la pratique on n'imagine pas des
gens allaient passer des visites
médicales pour savoir s'ils sont aptes
n'ont pas tous la poupe à toutes les 48
heures l'autre question qui intéresse
aussi beaucoup de gens si la carrière
qui va payer des tests pcr pour les
salariés qui veulent pas se faire
vacciner six mois d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est toutes les 48 heures qu'il
faudrait faire un test pcr
c'est l'employeur qui paye en principe
c'est à l'employeur le salarié n'a pas
exposé des frais pour exercer son
travail
là encore je ne sais pas évidemment des
alternatives existent pour éviter ce
genre de situation l'employé peut
mobiliser des jours de congés payés ou
des rtt mais il ne peut pas prétendre
aux allocations chômage
il a aussi aux problèmes notamment sur
la protection des salariés qui du jour
au lendemain
peuvent se retrouver sans rien le
salarié n'a pas droit au chômage
il n'a pas le droit de travailler
ailleurs et vous êtes dans un temps
suspendu
une sorte de no man's land où d'un côté
vous n'avez pas de sécurité économique
de l'autre côté vous n'avez pas de
sécurité juridique
l'inquiétude est de mise d'autant que ce
projet de loi voté dans l'urgence risque
clairement d'entraîner des vagues de
licenciements ou de démission dans des
secteurs déjà mises à mal par la crise
sanitaire
l'opposition n'a cessé de le répéter le
coc vide est temporaire les
licenciements sont définitifs
reste à savoir ce que les décrets
d'application de lois bon
les 6es ou pas